the Memphis Police Department has fired
a sixth officer for his alleged role in
the beating death of Tyree Nichols on
Friday the department announced Preston
Hemphill violated multiple policies
including the use of a stun gun Hemphill
was not at the location where Nichols
was beaten he was heard on body camera
footage stating he hopes officers stop
Nichols five other officers were already
fired and charged with second-degree
murder Nichol's death has led to renewed
impassioned calls for police reform CBS
News Congressional correspondent Nicole
Killian has more now from Capitol Hill
you are my strength as Tyree Nichols was
laid to rest this week we need to get
that bill passed amen a call to action
we demand that Congress passed the
George Floyd Justice and policing act
Joe Biden will sign it how can we make
some progress Thursday President Biden
and the vice president met with the
Congressional Black Caucus at the White
House to discuss potential executive
actions and legislation bad policing has
no place in any American city also in
that meeting Texas congresswoman Sheila
Jackson Lee who is working on a police
Reform Bill do you think it's possible
in this Congress
I'm going to say yes there is more
bipartisan agreement on what's in the
George Floyd Bill than what you would
think not the measure which limits
qualified immunity and would ban the use
of no knock warrants and chokeholds
passed twice in the house before
Republicans took control this year laser
220 the Nays are 212. the bill is passed
but negotiations fell apart in the
Senate after New Jersey Democrat Cory
Booker and South Carolina Republican Tim
Scott failed to reach a bipartisan
agreement we should have simple
legislation
that we can agree upon Scott and Booker
have continued conversations according
to Congressional sources but the GOP
Senator recently warned resurrecting
progressives police Reform Bill is a
non-starter how frustrated are you about
this uh enormously so Jackson Lee who
attended Nichols funeral this week and
spoke to his mother said she hopes any
new legislation could possibly include
his name I think we have a lot of
support for Tyree Nichols name being
part of the bill and we have a lot of
support for the idea of Duty to
intervene and duty to care there were
EMT persons who now have been caught up
in this tragedy because of inaction I'm
sure that hurt
Tyra's mother and so I wanted to assure
her his name should be attached to that
Tyree Nichols family is expected to be
at the State of the Union next week and
CBS News has learned other families
impacted by police brutality could be as
well for CBS Saturday morning Nicole
Killian Capitol Hill